this is your girl yeah he said no with
so much confidence like obviously
[ __ ] single you came out in
sweatpants what are you afraid of
honestly man I'm not gonna front you
terrify me a little bit middle-aged
white guy you're scared of this young
white kid right like it's not just me
being racist this is like a scary white
teen looking or Thor flick over here
just staring them daggers underneath I
know I told you I don't listen I'm not
everybody else all right I don't hate
white dudes you just you and I are
hopefully okay all right you got a list
just don't put me on that [ __ ]
please y'all please I'm not that guy all
right
I actually do think you're a good kid
but you're just the sweatpants really
[ __ ] me up I didn't I mean the guy
clearly doesn't care about anything
I guess it's Saturday night you live in
New York City where did you drive from
[ __ ] Des Moines or something
murderuss hat place like that where you
where you from buddy New Jersey this guy
knows who's getting so much confidence
this guy knows he's talking like he's on
stage holy [ __ ] I would ask you to come
to a joke but you're probably gonna
start laughing hysterically for no
reason because you got two conditions
Joe Bereta I do like you but I'm just
teasing you I hope I hope you don't take
any of us personally if you do let me
know and I will apologize right now
swear to god I'll [ __ ] do the Indian
thing and touch your feet in my head I
just don't know one of the problems you
know I don't want no problems over here
please you go my man came out cross
state lines in sweatpants
anything crazy ah sweatpants in a
flannel and he done said [ __ ] do you
know him
you don't right I nearly cookie came
alone I nearly came alone
I knew it [ __ ] I'm terrified I want you
to know I think you're a good person
people just need to love you do it if
you need a hug let me know I just got a
have Chief Pat you down make sure you
don't have any knives and a game on you
like that
and then I'll help you do not hold the
hug back in the back twice like a father
should have oh hold me to that just
don't hold me too long after and suck
all the air out of me
holy [ __ ] Jesus oh my god I'm sweating
I opened you rember when I open him I'm
not hating white guys you remember that
that was a thing that I believed that
was a thing that's a real thing I'm
walking less thank God holy [ __ ] you're
a good-looking guy you don't have to do
this you know what I mean
no homo or homo whatever the [ __ ] you
prefer yeah good-looking kid man world
is your oyster holy [ __ ] I hope you
didn't lose a scholarship to some Indian
kid otherwise I'm [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah get
your hand out of your pocket dog where
you going we're going man Jesus all
right
all jokes aside mostly jokes aside thank
you for being a good sport give it up
for this kid for being a good sport
[ __ ] oh my gosh I didn't have a good
night
[Applause]